experience is a comb that nature gives
to men when they are bald
[Music]
a pleasant voice brings a snake out of
its hole
[Music]
he who once a rose must beware of the
thorn
bravery without foresight is like a
blind horse
thinking is the essence of wisdom
[Music]
with a sweet tongue of kindness you can
drag an elephant by a hair
the arrow that has left the bow never
returns
the earth is a host who kills his guests
[Music]
the night hides a world but reveals a
universe
[Music]
do not cut down the tree that gives you
shade
habits are first cobwebs then cables
[Music]
drawn whales have sweetest water
trust in god but tie your camel tightly
a stone thrown at the right time might
be better than gold given at the wrong
time
the world is a rose smell it and pass it
on to your friends
do not use words that are too big for
your mouth
listening to good advice is the way of
wealth
[Music]
god gives to us according to the measure
of our hearts
[Music]
treat your superior as a father
your equal as a brother
and your inferior as a son
don't despise pepper because it is small
eat and see how pungent it is
one scabby goat infects the flock
[Music]
the eyes can do a thousand things that
the fingers can't
a sword in the hands of a drunken slave
is less dangerous than science in the
hands of an immoral man
thinking well is wise
planning well wiser
but doing well is the wisest and best of
all
[Music]
water long stagnant becomes putrid
[Music]
when its time has come
the prey goes to the hunter
the hand that gives is also the hand
that receives
[Music]
an ungrateful son is a wart on his
father's nose
he leaves it alone and it's ugly he
removes it and it hurts
[Music]
four walls make a man free
in the hour of adversity be not without
hope
to an ant a few drops of dew are a flood
the larger a man's roof the more snow it
collects
[Music]
take care lest your tongue cut off your
head
friendship with a fool may turn into a
hug from a bear
the best instruction is to practice what
you preach
maturity comes from wisdom
not in the passing of years
[Music]
doubt is the key to knowledge
[Music]
a diamond fallen into a dunghill is no
less precious
never open a door that you can't lock
again
[Music]
the big drum only sounds well from a
distance
[Music]
every man goes up to his death bearing
in his hands only that which he has
given away
[Music]
solved riddles look easy
if you tell the truth too early you are
laughed at
too late and you were stoned
a blind man who sees is better than a
sighted man who is blind
[Music]
the best memory is that which forgets
nothing but injuries
while yearning for excess we lose
necessities
[Music]
fear those who do not fear god
life is like perpetual drunkenness
the pleasure passes but the headache
remains
little by little the wool becomes a
carpet
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can close the city gates but you
can't close a person's mouth
[Music]
death is a camel that lies down at every
door
necessity changes a lion into a fox
[Music]
luck is infatuated with the efficient
a timely tear is better than a misplaced
smile
[Music]
in this world generous people have no
money
and those with money are not generous
[Music]
look in the sky not in the pond to find
the moon
[Music]
the way a house is decorated will tell
much about its owner
a greedy man is always poor
one sin is too much a hundred prayers
not enough
you cannot hang everything on one nail
[Music]
the guard sleep is the lamplight of the
thief
bribery makes both parties happy
right kindness in marble right injuries
in dust
[Music]
that smells bad said the cat about meat
it cannot reach
[Music]
the wise man who does not put his
knowledge into practice is like a bee
that gives no honey
[Music]
one pound of learning could require an
army of common sense to apply
there are three things that have to be
done quickly
burying the dead
opening the door for a stranger
and fixing your daughter's wedding
you can't pick up two melons with one
hand
the pleasure of finding something is
worth more than what you find
[Music]
he who doesn't go to war roars like a
lion
[Music]
once a friend always a friend
you can't escape death and guests
he whose heart is aroused by love will
never die
[Music]
the needle makes clothes but stays naked
[Music]
use your enemy's hand to catch a snake
[Music]
an arrow can be pulled out of a wound
but a hurtful word stays forever in your
heart
[Music]
when you are really thirsty
you don't desire a thousand pearls
you can't squeeze blood from a rock
when a cat wants to eat her kittens she
says they look like mice
when the snake is old the frog will
tease him
[Music]
if you enter the city of the blind cover
your eyes
the loveliest faces are to be seen by
moonlight when one sees half with the
eye and half with the fancy
our real grave is not in the ground but
in men's hearts
you don't put a wooden pot on the fire
twice
gold bears more gold
a beggar will always be a beggar even if
you give him the whole world
there are three kinds of enemies
your enemy himself
the friend of your enemy
and the enemy of your friend
[Music]
heaven is at the feet of mothers
deaths are like women once you have them
you can't get rid of them
[Music]
never marry a woman who has bigger feet
than you
you